[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce rendez-vous photo qui
est devenu maintenant récurrent avec
Claude bonjour bonjour Patrice alors
c'est vrai que on parle beaucoup
d'exposition on va d'ailleurs parler de
ce qui va se passer cet été à Paris en
région parisienne évidemment aux
Rencontres de la photo d'Arles mais mais
voilà parfois on oublie de parler de
vous qui avez aussi une oeuvre
photographique et bien on va consacrer
une partie de l'émission à vous parce
que d'ailleurs il y a des expositions où
on pourra voir vos photos et notamment
si vous allez dans l'Aveyron du côté de
Laissac
racontez-nous alors un peu c'est une
exposition commence vers le 14 juillet
bonjour Patrice c'est une exposition que
vous pouvez voir donc dans cette petite
ville de l'Aveyron les sacs c'est un
marché c'est le marché aux bestiaux ça
reste le premier marché aux besti de
France tous les ou tous les mardis c'est
ça se passe le mardi vous avez il se
vend pratiquement autour de 2000 à 2016
500 bêtes de bétail je dirais qu’il y a
presque plus d'habitants à Laissac que
de de
d'animaux
que vous avez de de d'habitants mais
vous avez déjà acheté vous des des
animaux
non mais déjà moi j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir faire des photos et de descendre
sur le foirail alors il faut se lever de
très bonheur ça commence à penser 6
heures du matin d'accord donc et
l'ouverture de marché se fait à partir
de 8h qui va être la le de 8h à 9h c'est
le marché
au bouvin qui partiront en boucherie et
de 9h à 10h c'est ce qu'on appelle les
broutards c'est les animaux qui vont
être achetés pour être engraissés dans
les sur les pâturages donc voilà
n'oublions pas que nous sommes allés
Aubrac et aujourd'hui c'est
essentiellement des bovins donc des des
bovins et maintenant il y a un
développement avec les ovins d'où le
pourquoi j'ai rajouté dans les photos
c'est
qui sont vraiment mignonnes comme pas
possible alors le marché
2500 personnes mais donc il y a les
vendeurs et qui sont pas forcément de
les sacs ils ont de la région
est quand même grand une région il y a
beaucoup d'animaux la viande au brac les
vaches sont quand même très braques
aussi elles sont magnifiques elles sont
très bien on dirait qu'elles sont
maquillées écoutez comme pour nous
séduire ces nouvelles corne voilà
incroyable regardez comme elle est belle
c'est vrai qu'elles sont magnifiques on
n'a pas envie on dirait qu'elle on
dirait qu'elles sont maquillées
on dirait qu'elle nous regarde surtout
il y a les vendeurs les vendeurs et les
acheteurs alors vous avez les comment
s'appelle les propriétaires qui sont
comment dire qui ont qui ont levé leur
beau vin dans des prairies des
agriculteurs et vous avez les maquillons
les maquignons ce qu'on appelle les
papillons aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de
sociétés comme
une société comme de d'achat de viande
groupée donc qui qui viennent acheter
des troupeaux complets et et la
caractéristique aussi c'est que la
négociation se fait en France
mais bon
marché est-ce essentiellement masculin
il y a très peu de femmes alors
cette mise en scène toutes ces mimiques
que vous avez le paysan le gars qui tend
la messe est un comment s'appelle un
acheteur et puis qui dit à ce
propriétaire mais non elles sont pas
belles femmes
et ça négocie alors que ça négocie ferme
et puis il faut voir les mimiques alors
vous avez les gens qui sont installés
déjà depuis pas mal de temps comme
maquignon alors tout le monde porte des
bottes une une crise avec un bâton parce
que parfois il y a eu quand même
quelques accidents des taureaux qui se
sont c'est pour ça qu'ils interdisent
aux gens de rentrer aux gens qui ne sont
pas des pour l'achat de vendeurs
d'interdire et moi j'ai eu cette chance
j'ai le droit d'y aller mais il faut y
aller aussi avec une paire de bottes
parce que sinon
mais c'est un moment c'est un moment où
les rapports humains sont quand même
très très proches on sent que les gens
se connaissent ils se connaissent ils se
connaissent le vendeur
ce personnage que je me suis permis de
photographier un jour il y a une dame
qui m'a dit mais ce monsieur illégal
j'ai regardé avec un peu des yeux
surpris quoi et elle me dit oui il est
célibataire
ah donc c'est vous voyez c'est et comme
vous pouvez voir Patrice sur le côté
droit de l'image vous avez ce rideau qui
partage le marché en deux donc là où se
trouve ce monsieur c'est le marché de
pour les bêtes qui vont partir en
boucherie de l'autre côté c'est les
moutards comme les appels et vous allez
c'est des photos qui que vous avez faite
sur plusieurs années surprise sur
plusieurs années donc j'ai fait toute
une série qu'on peut voir sur mon site
photo donc clôture.com ou justement je
raconte cette histoire qui est quand
même c'est c'est vraiment si vous voulez
un lieu de relation humaine et des
relations ce que j'appelle ça c'est le
marché
ouvert aux quatre vents
quand vous avez découvert c'est un de
mes amis qui m'a fait si vous n'êtes pas
bordelais c'est un de mes amis qui m'a
fait connaître il m'a dit qu'il y a une
maison là-bas
en Aveyron et qui m'a dit viens je vais
te faire découvrir quelque chose de
particulier et c'est vrai que l'Aveyron
c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut mériter parce qu'il faut y
aller
mais elle est magnifique il y a des il y
a des cuisines comme bras par exemple
qui sont des exceptionnels et puis il y
avait un peintre célèbre aussi qui est
Pierre soulage qui était
originaire de Rodez Rodez c'est dans le
chef du département quoi et d'ailleurs
on verra bientôt des photos de Claude
chose au musée de soulage de Rodez
donc ça ça c'est un pont de votre de
votre travail et c'est beau parce que
c'est c'est à la fois un monde qui
existe mais c'est aussi un peu un monde
qui disparaît non alors effectivement
comme vous le dites Patrice ce monde
peut-être disparaît parce qu'aujourd'hui
les grandes sociétés de viande comme
n'est pas beaucoup font voir les
éleveurs directement et négocier donc
mais dans les marchés il y a un peu
moins voilà c'est c'est le maquignon
voilà
fils quand même souvent donc et mais moi
je j'invite les gens qui passent pas
loin de l'Aveyron le mardi c'est le
mardi à partir de 8 mois
il y a une mise en scène extraordinaire
de voir les gens de les observer
regardez avec quel détermination ils ont
l'air de partir donc donc c'est leur vie
donc sur leur vie c'est leur existence
c'est le fruit de leur travail qui a été
vendu là et donc là je vais exposer
alors à partir du 14 juillet
en extérieur c'est une photo de 1m30 par
mètre
et sur trois ans ils vont l'exposer
pendant 3 ans d'accord donc pourquoi
noir et blanc
parce que la couleur
c'est plus authentique
peut-être avec ce type de marché qui
aujourd'hui est en voie des disparitions
entre deux mondes on sent bien que voilà
on n'est pas ça existe donc on n'est pas
dans le passé c'est encore mais on sent
bien que c'est un monde qui est en train
de se changer
mais c'est un monde de vrai voilà c'est
les gens sont ce que j'appelle dans dans
cette région les les gens que parce
qu'aujourd'hui je connais quand même pas
mal de gens j'ai appris grâce à cet ami
à découvrir des associations les gens
ils savent ils sont en association et
vraiment ils travaillent il va il
travaille vraiment très très dur et
comme me disait
un éleveur qui me disait mais le petit
quand il est il est tout mignon puis la
façon dont vous voyez il le disait il a
il est tout bouclé il est tout mignon
quoi on le caresse on sent que ces gens
ils ont vraiment pour leur pour leur
pour leurs animaux les sacs c'est quoi à
côté de quoi de Villefranche c'est pas
que le château quand on prend
l'autoroute quand on prend l'autoroute
qui part de Clermont-Ferrand qui descend
vers Montpellier à un moment on voit il
y a on voit la nationale 88 qui permet
d'aller vers Rodez et c'est vrai que
c'est pas très loin donc de et les sacs
pardon c'est pas très loin de ses bras
que le château c'est vrai que l'Église
d'accord moi j'ai découvert des régions
qui sont super ne serait-ce que le GR 65
qui fait donc qui est le Compostelle il
y a des il y a des coins si vous voulez
qu'ils sont d'ailleurs on verra
peut-être tout à l'heure quelques photos
moi j'ai fait j'ai fait des photos
là-bas c'est des paysages
tu étais seul avec le ventre je trouve
que c'est c'est aussi ça a une certaine
beauté de ce paysage il y a des cascades
il y a des lacs il y a parce que bon ça
a été une région volcanique dans très
longtemps et c'est ça qui est
intéressant et cette vache je l'ai elle
a déjà été exposée à cette
sur l'autre ça veut dire l'autre en
comment s'appelle en occitan excitant
donc c'est je connais aussi Estaing j'ai
un ami qui habite à Estaing où il y a le
château de l'ancien président de la
République il a racheté parce que pour
pour croire qu'il était destin
mais bon
Périer le le photographe de François
Périer qui était le photographe et puis
et puis il y a la gueule à la gueule il
faut aller voir
c'est là qu'il y a les bras le la
fameuse
et puis et puis il y a aussi une
fabrique de couteaux ou pas parce que
c'est contesté ça comment on refait les
couteaux à la yole alors il y avait une
émission sur M6 qui avait dit 80% des
couteaux
à l'extérieur mais la lame de la yole
c'est une usine qui était
construite en fait qui a été aménagé par
comment il s'appelle le nom m'échappe ce
bon ça reviendra et donc où on voit la
fabrication des couteaux d'accord et là
on est sûr d'acheter un couteau un vrai
ou d'ailleurs sur le couteau il y a une
petite particularité il y a la croix du
berger l'abeille
pas une abeille c'est comme ça
il y a aussi la croix du berger qui
permet aux gens qui gardent les
troupeaux dans les pâturages de pouvoir
se recueillir sur ça il y a beaucoup de
choses à faire dans l'Aveyron
un mot alors parce que ça c'est une
partie de votre travail les sacs il y a
d'autres
c'est pas seulement des photos de marché
je fais beaucoup d'autres sujets alors
la photo que
moi j'ai c'est mon père qui m'a un peu
dirigé vers cette travail photographique
parce que je l'ai vu coloriser des
photos dans les années ça 55 60 donc ça
m'a ça m'étonnait de voir mon père si tu
veux faire ça et donc j'ai découvert un
photographe antique bien sûr j'ai
travaillé avec que ça soit noir et blanc
en couleur et j'ai aussi
après après appréhender le numérique
quand il est arrivé dans les années 2000
et avec des amis quand j'ai habité
voisin de Bretonneux puisque j'ai habité
par moments à Voisins-le-Bretonneux nous
avons fondé le Photo Club de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux donc qui
aujourd'hui existe toujours ça c'est des
photos de vous ça c'est des photos de
moi oui d'accord donc c'est des photos
faites au studio c'est pas ce que je
préfère vous c'est pas mal je mais
j'aime faire ça c'est joli quand même
c'est c'est très très agréable à faire
il faut avoir de l'imagination ça c'est
pas évident et puis le modèle mais
ce que je peux vous dire Patrice c'est
que le modèle un
que j'ai croisé dans le dans le parc de
Versailles et je l'avais photographié et
elle lui demandais d'abord je lui ai
demandé elle a accepté très gentille
très sympathique très sympa alors elle
m'a même traité de comment il m'a dit
d'amateur parce que j'avais gardé le
bouchon sur mon objectif mais comme
j'étais comme j'ai des appareils
réflexes automatiquement je vois à
travers l'objectif voilà mais elle est
très amusante très très
c'est une jeune femme alors ça c'est
Philippe Jaroussky est absolument donc
contre
ténor photographier
exceptionnel un peu c'est comme les
castrats quoi ça vient c'est le nom
qu'on leur a donné parce qu'il vient ça
veut dire je suis russe je suis russe
c'est arrivé voilà c'est ça
et c'est un garçon alors ça
tout à l'heure on parlera peut-être de
des Rencontres d'Arles là vous avez
c'est une photo que j'ai faite en 2009
juillet 2009 quand Willy rooneis le
personnage à gauche avait invité invités
d'Arles donc il était venu pendant 8
jours malheureusement de mois après il
nous a quitté mais il avait quand même
99 ans
Lucien Clerc c'est le créateur des
rencontres d'art créateurs il a commencé
avec en 1970 il avait invité Amselle
Adam ce qui était venu entre la dame ce
grand photographe américain qui était
venu qui était venu en Marne et c'est de
là que ça a démarré et petit à petit ça
c'est ça se perpétue donc de livres de
photos de Clem sur Picasso notamment
la photo qu'il a faite de Picasso est
extraordinaire et il a convaincu Picasso
en lui montrant des photos qu'il avait
faites de corrida alors je sais que la
corrida c'est
il y a des
superbes dessins de Picasso sur la
corrida oui oui tout à fait et puis il y
a aussi un autre photographe qui a fait
de très belles photos de Picasso c'est
iruin en ce moment avec qui expose à
parler à Deauville donc à savoir voilà
donc ça c'est des photos assez elle est
belle celle-là c'est des photos ça c'est
un photographe que j'ai rencontré
l'année dernière
je suis très orienté en termes de photos
si vous voulez sur la partie humaine de
photographier les gens la nature il y a
des grands photographes de nature qui
existent mais c'est ce qu'on voit dans
dans l'expo qu'on peut voir les sacs ce
qui est ce qui est ce qui est magnifique
c'est des visages c'est les expressions
les humains l'humanité l'humanité alors
quand je photographie les humains en
général je demande
Patrice
en Arles il y a plusieurs années et
c'était Jr vous savez ce monsieur d'or
ce monsieur
et qui avait découvert d'ailleurs le
pont c'est le pont Louis-Philippe avec
des yeux qui regardaient donc
il a fait des il a fait une exposition
aussi au Moyen-Orient avec des
Palestiniens et des Palestiniens très
bien donc voilà c'est un monsieur qui
voudrait que les gens arrivent en fin de
ce parfait alors des choses ce type
d'Afrique du Sud aussi avec les
je le connaisse les interviewer c'est un
petit peu incroyable cette photo
aujourd'hui je me suis penché sur un
travail un peu particulier
l'avènement du téléphone portable des
smartphones comment regarder dans cette
image cette femme elle est absorbée par
son téléphone et regarder son compagnon
et ce qui était assez surprenant c'est
vrai que c'est que des gens au
restaurant
je présume c'est tout un travail que qui
m'amuse de faire ça voilà
Bresson photographier c'est voir ce que
les autres ne voient pas tout à fait et
là c'est vraiment le cas
nous parle un peu on sait pas s'il se
parle vraiment ça c'est je fais aussi
beaucoup de ce qu'on appelle la photo de
rue la suite photo donc ça c'est un une
image que j'ai faite à Lyon au cours
d'un de mes voyages professionnels et
j'étais rentré dans ce bar que je
trouvais assez atypique et j'avais
demandé de le photographier donc c'est
voilà c'est super
comme on les aime alors ça c'est une
photo j'ai fait à Bordeaux sur le miroir
d'eau et j'ai un peu l'impression si
vous voyez le film de rencontre du
troisième type
quand à la fin il y a iti qui repartent
et ce bébé qui est marcher sur le miroir
d'eau ça me faisait penser à ça j'ai
toujours une je suis assez cinéphile et
j'aime bien les références de prendre
des références par exemple je vais vous
citer le nom et une femme à la fin qui
empruntignan et à nous qui met se
retrouve ce personnage qui marche sur la
plage avec son chien je trouve que c'est
extraordinaire cette d'avoir à penser à
prendre cette photo donc et donc c'est
un peu ce qui guide mon travail
photographique alors ça c'est une photo
que j'ai faite rue Saint-André des Arts
alors ce que j'aime bien c'est ce
monsieur c'est un routard je vais dire
qui est en train de se raser sur les
marches d'un opticien et c'est la
relation qu'on peut avoir avec la photo
de la
gauche le visage de cette femme et ce
monsieur qui est en train de se raser
avec dans une une cuvette en al voilà
c'est ça c'est des photos faites dans le
métro
c'est ce que j'avais
c'est le point commun même avec le
marché des bestiaux de sacs c'est ça
c'est l'aventure humaine quoi et là
c'est j'avais une intitulé intitulé
cette série que toujours visible sur mon
site aussi mais
les gens ne regardent pas quoi vous qui
passez sans me voir j'étais repartis un
peu sur le thème de cette chanson de qui
passera voilà c'est ça l'indifférence
des gens et je crois que c'est comment
il s'appelle Yehudi Menuhin qui avait
fait un concert à New York où les gens
avaient payé pour cher pour assister au
métropolitanes et le lendemain il a joué
dans le métro les gens sont regardés
donc voilà ça c'est drôle donc c'est des
choses comme ça
moi je trouve que c'est vrai qu'on
regarde pas on regarde pas ce qui se
passe regarde pas ce qui se passe et
mais enfin il faut voir c'est vrai qu'il
faut on est pris par le temps on est
pris je ne sais pas par quoi enfin une
sorte d'effervescence
c'est vrai que c'est peut-être que
peut-être que maintenant qu'on va rouler
peut-être plus à vélo c'est comme ça
avec vous avez raison qu'on aura un peu
plus de regarder ce qui est autour de
soi mais quoi qu'il faut faire attention
aux voitures
de travail alors ça c'est pas celui
qu'on verra les sacs évidemment mais
c'est vraiment les bestiaux mais j'ai
des photos que j'ai exposées au carré la
farine à Versailles j'ai exposé à Épône
je fais pas mal d'expositions et donc il
y aura
prochainement
il vient d'avoir une exposition belle
elle s'est terminée elle se termine
demain
donc où j'ai exposé aussi alors ce que
j'ai fait c'est un travail qui pour moi
est assez important c'est je suis allé
sur les quais de scène à Paris où vous
avez l'été des gens qui dansent donc
j'ai fait plusieurs photos et
j'ai photographié ça c'est il y a des
gens qui dansent sur le rock mais vous
avez des gens aussi qui dansaient la
salsa et la salsa c'est un peu lié avec
mes origines puisque ma maman était
d'origine martiniquaise alors ça c'est
des photos que j'ai faite avec un 24 mm
donc pour vous dire que c'est une focale
très courte sans flash sans rien donc ou
après j'ai été obligé de travailler de
retravailler mes photos pour cette
histoire c'est le soir le soir et donc
j'ai fait toute une série de photos et
avec j'avais présenté un dossier complet
un soir d'été parole de danse où j'avais
été primé dans un concours donc avec ça
parce que quand on regarde le regard et
le mouvement dans la danse évidemment
vous voyez donc parce que ma mère était
une mère des Antilles c'est une c'est
une danse qui pratique c'est pratique
là-bas et alors c'est assez surprenant
on voit beaucoup de de d'Anthia qui sont
là qui dansent avec des européennes donc
ça
va alors
et puis on voit dans le regard le
plaisir parce que j'étais à mettre à
peine des gens donc il me voyaient
prendre des photos et ça les gênait pas
au contraire il y en a même qui posait
pour moi donc
comme je vous offre Patrice moi je vais
vers les gens et je leur demande
des choses quand même regarder le regard
de cette femme même si la photo elle est
peut-être floue elle est elle a
peut-être des défauts mais qu'est-ce qui
est important c'est l'intention du
photographe c'est pas de c'est pas la
technique comme je dis souvent c'est pas
parce que vous avez le meilleur appareil
du monde
photos c'est d'abord votre regard qui
est le plus important mais je ne fais
pas que ça
je ne fais pas que ça alors ça c'est
j'ai tenu à mettre cette image parce que
c'est une image que j'ai prise pas loin
d'ici
mais quand il y a pas il y a une dizaine
d'années c'est à côté de comment
s'appelle de challenger vous avez ce
petit village qui existe où il y avait
ce magasin qui existaient dans le passé
donc je tiens beaucoup à cette image
parce que elle a quelque chose c'est le
cycle passé c'est le siècle passé tout à
fait vous avez raison de lire ça tant
que
et puis il y a aussi l'autre extrémité
ça c'est de ça c'est la
bnfers
que j'aime beaucoup dans cette photo
c'est c'est les reflets qu'il y a dans
dans cette
après je suis pas sûr des problèmes de
conservation des livres je crois mais
entre autres vous avez ça et puis on
verra l'architecte l'architecte pays
c'est aussi ce patio qui a été fait avec
la forêt qui est au milieu et puis vous
avez aussi les globes de Coronelli qui
sont exposés là-bas
géographe italien qui a offert deux
globes à Louis XIV un qui représente le
ciel astral le jour de sa naissance est
tel qu'on connaissait le monde à son
époque c'est à dire avec les quatre
continents et puis ça c'est vous devriez
connaître ça
non dites-moi ben écoute
quand on a fait la première Biennale
d'un photographique à 50 ans en Yvelines
c'est faisait partie de l'image sur la
fiche donc et d'ailleurs regardez
derrière vous avez le bâtiment
on est à regarder on est on est en bas
donc voilà c'est c'est assez
ça qui est bien dans la photo c'est
qu'on voit les choses qu'on les a jamais
vu voilà et surtout c'est c'est un
moment qui ne se reproduira
et ça c'est une c'est une série de
photos que j'ai faite que j'ai que j'ai
appelé Fils de vie j'étais inspiré par
le poème de la nouvelle de Jean
d'Ormesson sur le train de la vie où il
raconte qu'on trouve facilement sur
Internet où il raconte que on monte dans
un train où il y a ses parents et puis
au fur et à mesure il y a des gens qui
descendent et c'est je dirais
c'est une photo qui fait au smartphone
sur les reflets sur les reflets quand il
a plu et que vous retravailler après ah
oui oui bien sûr c'est clair
mais parce que la photo c'est aussi pour
moi c'est aussi d'aller au bout de son
expression de d'aller dans ce qu'on veut
représenter et donc c'est ça qui est le
plus intéressant donc mais j'aime
beaucoup cette série cette série que
j'ai explosé déjà à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux
j'aime beaucoup cette série de photos
c'est ça c'est chez moi c'est le banc
d'Arguin qui était
une photo faite d'en haut de la dune du
Pilates je rappelle au passage la dune
du péage la plus haute dune d'Europe 110
mètres de haut c'est facile à monter
dans un sens on peut descendre après au
bord de la mer mais remonter côté merci
plus difficile
et la dune elle avance
ça c'est assez amusant c'est de voir ces
tous ces blockhaus qui ont été
construits par dans la deuxième guerre
mondiale qui aujourd'hui finissent
souvent au fond de la mer à 30 mètres
sous le niveau de la mer alors qu'ils
étaient sur des dunes c'est c'est la
nature qui qui les avale
la mer gagne oui puisque je crois qu'il
y a un monsieur qui habite à la pointe
du café et absolument et qui construit
et qui construit qui aimait
qui permet de montrer que après les
blockhaus c'est bien le numéro prend la
reprend ses droits sur la nature avec la
nature donc
une image simple beaucoup de gens
pensent que c'est une aquarelle alors
que non une image que j'ai faite dans un
grand format que j'avais exposé aussi à
Versailles à Voisins donc et puis on
peut quelques mots sur l'architecture de
Versailles quand même parce que j'ai
aussi pas mal de choses là-dessus donc
ça ça fait partie d'une série que Louis
XIV avait écrit un des nouvelles pour
faire visiter les jardins de Versailles
à ses amis il a écrit 6 livres pour
faire ça oui
et ça c'est Versailles sous la neige
j'aime beaucoup cette photo
le bassin de l'atome était pris sous la
tempête de neige c'est rare de pouvoir
le faire parce que généralement tu es
une tempête voyez il ferme tout de suite
le parc
et puis et puis ça c'est tout le
statuaire de Versailles donc qui est
absolument magnifique mais aujourd'hui
beaucoup de ces statuts sont des copies
puisque le château de sauvegarder toutes
les
originaux dans la
les la galerie de des petites écuries
d'accord
vous avez la tôle vous avez tous les
toutes les grandes sculptures qui ont
été faites donc et là je vous amène dans
les souterrains du château en fait du
château du parc c'est là où tout vous
avez toutes les canalisations
dans les mais je crois qu'il y a des
gens qui l'ont fait peut-être mieux que
moi mais qui qui ont montré
effectivement vous avez 35 km de
galeries sous le parc de Versailles
parce que toute les bassins fonctionne
par gravité ça c'est c'est sous la
comment s'appelle sous le bassin de
l'atome l'araignée la fameuse araignée
que nous avons vu en 19
en 2013 qui pesait 5 tonnes de plombs et
alors ce qui caractéristique c'est que à
des endroits vous avez de la fleur de
lys du roi ah d'accord donc c'est voyez
tous les tous les robinets donc et puis
à l'heure actuelle on peut j'ai pas mis
de photos de ça mais vous avez
ce comment s'appelle le buffet d'eau qui
a été restauré à dans le parc de Trianon
et puis ça bien sûr c'est c'est comment
s'appelle le patient de la police dans
le brouillard
cette photo elle est
je l'ai offerte d'ailleurs à deux trois
personnes du service des eaux parce que
alors là juste une petite anecdote
partout vous allez dans le château de
Versailles le vous avez des bus de Louis
XIV avec un cours de tête très altier
il domine dominateur et là si vous quand
on regarde parce que j'ai une photo
beaucoup plus proche de la statue et là
on voit que Louis Apollon Louis XIV
puisque Roi Soleil du soleil baisse la
tête
et on peut se poser la question quoi
pourquoi parce que à ses pieds il y a
l'archange qui représente Dieu sachant
que la monarchie française est une
monarchie de droit divin qui n'avait de
compensation ça c'est une série sur les
escaliers
donc
voilà tout ce que je peux vous dire en
fait il y a beaucoup d'autres choses à
dire parce que Versailles c'est un
domaine alors c'est vrai que j'habite
pas loin j'y vais souvent je suis
curieux
le dernier travail ça c'est le plafond
du salon de de la paix
mais la photo originale est plus moins
moins dur que celle-ci et ça c'est le
temple de l'Amour dans le jardin de
triangle mais pour la faire il faut un
grand angle parce que sinon on met pas
tout dans le cadre
superbe donc c'est assez superbe j'ai
aussi des photos du palmier à Toulouse
parce que quand je vais en province je
fais aussi des photos je n'en fais pas
qu'à Versailles mais je comme je vous
disais tout à l'heure je travaille
essentiellement je partage des émotions
avec mes photos c'est je fais partager
des émotions c'est pas juste pour faire
c'est pas juste c'est pas la photo de
tout risque voilà je suis pas dans ça je
fais des séries de photographies qui
racontent une histoire une émotion des
émotions comme on disait dans le travail
d'auteur et j'aime beaucoup cette photo
c'est l'ombre de la statue de Louis XIV
des grandes écuries j'ai fait un travail
sur aussi les les vertus du roi à savoir
que Louis XIV et 14 vertus
ah oui donc voilà
14 statues et j'en ai fait un scrabook
ça c'est Manaus au Brésil non ça va là
on s'en va vous trouvez pas Patrice qui
a un côté ou peur dans cette photo
donc voilà c'est
ce à quoi j'ai pensé quand j'ai fait
cette photo j'ai travaillé là-bas
pendant plus d'un an et demi à manaros
donc pour vous donner une idée manao
c'était à 5 heures d'avion de de Rio
donc c'est ça donne une idée de ça c'est
une marchande de journaux que
qui avait été que j'ai photographié
là-bas le matin en allant chercher puis
il y a quelque chose alors ça c'est le
les mangrove que vous avez autour de
parce que à manaro si passe une rivière
qui en fait une rivière car je parle
rivière fait 8 km de large donc c'est ça
vous donne la dimension qui n'est pas
loin qui qui varie entre 10 et 12 mètres
entre les autres os et les basesos
c'est-à-dire que les gens voyaient les
maisons qu'ils habitent en revanche ils
ont tous la télé c'est ça
des antennes les antennes là donc voilà
quand on voit des invités
de soleil que vous avez là-bas est-ce
que savoir que à 6h il commence à faire
nuit à 6h30 il fait nuit totale
puisqu'on n'est pas loin de l'équateur
mais il y a une image que j'aurais voulu
vous montrer c'est là comment c'est
facile à vivre
il faut avoir un bon imperméable parce
que quand il se met à pleuvoir
en 10 gouttes vous êtes mouillé
complètement c'est les Russes se
transforment en ruisseau mais il y a une
image que qui est très intéressante que
qui a été refaite qui a été faite aussi
par Salgado qui est la rencontre du Rio
Negro et du Rio sur les noces qui font
l'Amazone sur ça voilà c'est cette image
elle est pour moi les plus elle est plus
belle en couleur puisque vous avez
l'impression d'une marée noire d'une
marée noire sur une plage parce que le
rayon des gros est noir et l'autre
rivière qui arrive elle est belge
donc ça fait et les gens que le premier
voyage que j'ai fait là-bas ils nous ont
tous tous les gens qu'on a raconté nous
dit on voulait aller voir l'opéra tu
sais parce que le Yao aussi vous savez
qu'il y a eu cette construction par les
Européennes de l'Opéra de manausoleil
ou il récolter le comment s'appelle le
caoutchouc et il nous a dit ils nous ont
tous dit si vous devez aller voir
quelque chose il faut aller voir cette
rencontre entre les deux fleuves voilà
parce que c'est ce qu'il faut l'Amazone
et je pense que vous savez ça aussi que
parce que je crois que vous lisez
beaucoup de livres la façon dont cet
opéra a été construite tous les
matériaux étaient fermés en Europe par
des Italiens et puis peut-être des
français et tous les matériaux étaient
transportés depuis l'Europe jusqu'à
Manaus mais à l'époque l'Amazone dépanne
navigable donc ça veut dire que à chaque
cataracte il devait sortir tout le
matériel sortir le bateau de l'eau et je
crois qu'il y a un livre qui a été écrit
sur cette sur cette période
ça revoit les
donc c'est non non non non
donc ça c'est des images de corridables
j'aime bien c'est c'est moi je suis
passionné par la corrida alors je sais
que c'est pas bien de le dire mais
à la fin de la corrida la cavalière
parce que c'est les corridas
c'est une femme qui descend de son
cheval et qui
annoncé
et puis un jour dans le parc de
Versailles j'ai vu ça
vous imaginez Patrice ce monsieur dit un
journal
plus beaucoup donc voilà c'est pour ça
que je trouve cette image assez
intéressante donc
et puis ça c'est ce que j'appelle la
vidéo surveillance
donc
ça mais comme vous pouvez remarquer sur
mes photos il y a toujours l'humain a
toujours une place
ça c'est Deauville quand il y a les
séances photographiques donc c'est des
paysages que bon ce qui me qui me
captive aussi qui sont intéressants à
regarder parce que on voit bien que
c'est au mois de novembre en partant
relativement froid donc avec beaucoup de
ventes donc c'est ce sont des choses
aussi et puis ça évoque c'est aussi
cette solitude de ce lieu qui était
donc très
vite comme ça
[Musique]
et puis ça donc on revient sur Arles je
vous ai mis là Arles Arles comme on
disait tout à l'heure ça a été créé dans
les années 1970 par Lucien Clerc contre
photographique et donc il y a deux c'est
un moment incontournable pour les pour
les photos qui aiment la photo qu'il
faut aller voir même si vous voyez on
n'est pas tout à fait d'accord avec ce
que l'on voit parce que ça
mais il faut y parce que c'est les
tendances nouvelles alors ça c'est un
ami que j'ai photographié et il me dit
tu vois j'ai mon portrait chez mon
portrait en même temps c'est il
s'appelle William
William et c'est un photographe qui est
connu quand même un bon pas mondialement
mais qui est bien connu et William Rodez
alors il va y avoir des
pas mal de photographies ça c'est c'est
clair
c'est l'ensemble parce que Arles il y a
cette partie euh les caractéristiques la
première semaine c'est là où on
rencontre tous les photographes d'accord
on peut rencontrer même si on est il y a
aucun problème ils sont très accessibles
et la preuve tout à l'heure c'est avec
l'image de Willy Ronis ils ont posé pour
moi donc j'étais face à eux et pendant
cette semaine il y a aussi ce qu'on
appelle le Off
donc des gens qui vont aider
le festival et donc l'eau fait quelque
chose et souvent parfois et souvent
intéressant plus intéressant que le
parce que les alors ça c'est le soir
vous avez des jeunes là qui ont lieu de
casser les vitrines et ben ils vendent
leur bouquins et c'est assez rare quoi
donc c'est ce côté magique qu'on
rencontre là-bas autour de la photo dans
le sud et là il y avait des soirées
assez électro donc
j'ai mis une ou deux photos pour montrer
ce qui est et le festival d'Arles le
hing du RUP pratiquement jusqu'à la
mi-septembre
la première semaine
la toile jaune que vous voyez derrière
c'est était l'endroit où Van Gogh a
venait donc boire de la viande puisque
il a été il a passé quelques quelques
temps donc voilà il y a un espace qui
s'appelle l'espace Mango et je
je pense que vous vous souvenez
lorsqu'il y a eu son exposition cette
exposition de rétrospective à la
Fondation Vuitton où on avait montré
cette
ce tableau
oui santé prisonnier les prisonniers
donc qui tournait dans une salle alors
que il était dans un hôpital
psychiatrique donc là vous avez l'école
3 juillet 24 septembre
quand on passe pas loin il faut aussi
arrêter qui s'arrête qui s'intéresse à
la photo mais en revanche il faut savoir
marcher aussi parce que
pas bien en voiture il fait un peu chaud
Patrick si vous êtes gentil quand vous
êtes une trentaine degrés voire plus et
puis vous avez des moustiques vous avez
une place adorable la place du Forum la
place du Forum oui donc il y a les
statues d'ailleurs de il y avait des
statues de
les arbres ce qui fait que c'est là
non non mais c'est et puis vous avez et
puis vous allez pouvoir
les bords du Rhône et surtout moi
je n'évite je conseillerai aussi d'aller
visiter le musée d'art antique qui est
un très très beau musée quoi donc ce
niveau parce que ils ont retrouvé cette
ville qui a été florissante à l'époque
gallo-romaine ils ont retrouvé beaucoup
d'objets qui étaient qui sont tombés
dans le Rhône et donc le buste de Jules
César oui il y a d'ailleurs un hôtel qui
s'appelle
qui sont à voir aussi et puis vous avez
aussi les anciens ateliers de comment
s'appelle de SNCF ou sont été présentés
aujourd'hui ça diminue puisque Maya
Hoffman l'héritière des laboratoires a
fait cette tour
il y a ce centre culturel
mais ça a perdu fondation cette
fondation la Fondation mais ça a perdu
un petit peu de son charme peut-être la
Fondation
magnifique très bien alors un mot sur ce
qui va se passer cet été à Paris à Paris
il va se passer beaucoup de choses que
j'ai noté
il y a au Jeu de Paume vous avez
l'exposition De Franc Corbas francova
est un grand photographe de mode qui a
mis la photo de mode dans la rue au Jeu
de Paume je pour ceux que ça intéresse
je vous conseille fortement d'aller voir
cette exposition il y a 160
photos de très grande qualité c'est
vraiment un moment d'émer
d'émerveillement vous avez aussi au
musée maillot le héliotherwist
l'exposition continue encore
j'en avais déjà parlé mais il faut aller
la voir parce que c'est un photographe
qui avait beaucoup d'humour qui a su
photographe
parfois des américains avec les chiens
compagnie vous avez aussi la femme de
John bateau qui a été une grande
photographe noir et blanc à visiter
aussi dans Paris je me rappelle plus
mais je vous donne je pourrais vous
donner l'adresse et j'ai beaucoup aimé
aussi cette ce photographe qui explose à
la Maison du Japon à Paris à côté de
Birken
c'est un photographe réaliste de ce
qu'est le Japon et tout ça c'est visible
tous les pays et c'est pas fini il y a
aussi Harry Guyard qui est aussi
quelqu'un qui faut voir c'est un belge
qui a fait des photos sur la Belgique et
qui sont vraiment très très belles en
couleur avec des excès de
des excès et puis je crois que c'est en
Arles il y a aussi saute later qui est
un monsieur qui a fait des photos qui a
fait son des photos de pluie en couleur
quand il était dans des bars avec vous
voyez tout ce qui exprime la buée qui
peut y avoir par rapport à
c'est assez intéressant à voir mais pour
ça il faudra aller en Arles voilà génial
on a fait un tour
qui aiment la photo là ils ont habillé
de Claude donc moi je vous remercie pour
cet accueil Patrice et puis je trouve
que si vous le souhaitez on pourra
continuerai un retour complet sur Arles
voilà ok merci beaucoup Claude chose
merci à vous et vive la photo
la photo n'oubliez pas c'est voir ce que
les autres ne voient pas là il faut
sauver
si vous devenez observateur pour trouver
des choses superbe à photographe voilà
merci beaucoup Claude merci à toi à vous
Patrice pardon
[Musique]